c'est donc à tour que le 15 du Trèfle va
vivre sa coupe du monde de rugby 2023
annonce officialisé hier hôtel centre
d'entraînement piscine on vous présente
les lieux que fréquenteront le staff et
les joueurs de ce qui est aujourd'hui la
meilleure équipe du monde des lieux
choisis pour leur aspect évidemment
pratique avec des aménagements des lieux
qui leur garantiront aussi un maximum de
discrétion Hélène chapelet
c'est derrière les grilles de ce parc de
plus de deux hectares que les joueurs du
15 du Trèfle vont être hébergés durant
leur séjour tout rangeau en septembre
prochain un hôtel 4 étoiles qui sera
entièrement privatisé pour l'occasion
les 65 chambres de l'établissement
seront uniquement occupés par les
rugbymen et leur staff et les 60
employés du site et leur direction
seront d'ailleurs aux petits soins pour
ses hôtes de marque c'est là où ils vont
se sentir bien c'est là où ils vont se
préparer ou ils vont recevoir de la
famille ou ils vont se dire bon allez on
y va et ça va être vraiment
leur maison dédiée en France étant donné
que le site et les privatisé ils vont
avoir toutes les infrastructures donc
nous avons un espace à faire ils vont
avoir la partie château avec toute la
partie restauration et puis l'espace
bien-être pour se détendre
situé à moins de 4 km de là le stade de
la chambreerie c'est là que les rugbyman
irlandais viendront s'entraîner sur
place d'ailleurs les travaux se
poursuivent pour qu'ils puissent
bénéficier d'équipements flambants neuf
près de 4 millions d'euros ont été
investis pour créer une salle de
musculation de 300 mètres carrés et une
dizaine de vestiaires et là encore le
temps de la compétition le site sera
réservé aux Irlandais ici ça va être
complètement fermé ça il y a aucune
possibilité ils ont même exigé d'avoir
des brise-vue et tout pour que les gens
ne puissent pas regarder parce que là ce
sont les séances d'entraînement où ils
vont répéter toutes les combinaisons et
tout en revanche
normalement il y a des séances
d'entraînement qui doivent être ouvertes
au public et alors ça ça se passera au
stade de la Vallée du Cher
enfin toujours à Tours Nord pour se
délasser entre deux rencontres ou deux
entraînements les joueurs irlandais
pourront compter sur la piscine des
Tourettes le bassin de 25 mètres leur
sera alors réservé